Die ERCP. Wir möchten bei Ihnen eine sogenannte ERCP durchführen. Das ist ein Verfahren, bei dem wir mit einem speziellen Instrument durch den Mund bis in den 12-Fingerdarm gehen.
Das Instrument ist ein langer, dünner Schlauch mit Lichtquille und Kamera am Ende. Dieser Schlauch wird durch den Mund bis zum 12-Fingerdarm vorgeschoben.
Außerdem verwenden wir dabei auch ein sogenanntes Kontrastmitte und Röntgenstrahlen, um die Geilengänge sichtbar zu machen.
Sollten wir dabei einen Geilenstein finden, dann können wir diesen in den meisten Fällen auch gleich entfernen.
Das Verfahren ist schmerzlos, aber kann unangenehm sein. Deshalb bekommen Sie einen Beruhigungsmittel.
Auf die Rückfrage, ob das nun eine Narcose ist, sagen Sie, nein, das ist so ähnlich, aber keine richtige Narcose.
Sie bekommen weniger vom Eingriff mit, sind aber danach auch schneller wieder wach.
Wann möchten Sie das machen? Wenn sich der Verdacht auf Geilensteine bestätigt, also wenn wir Geilensteine im Ultraschall finden, dann sollten wir diese Untersuchung möglichst schnell machen.
Wie lange dauert der Eingriff? Das dauert ungefähr eine Stunde, aber das hängt davon ab, was wir bei der Untersuchung finden.
Sie sollten nach dem Eingriff noch ein bis zwei Tage oder auch ein paar Stunden bei unserem Krankenhaus bleiben, um möglichen Komplikationen vorzubeugen.